irie study every piece that I that I
conduct at least a little bit before I
go on stage even pieces that I know very
well that I've done many many times I
flip through the score and I make sure
that my mind is there it's the
phenomenon of coming to it a second time
if something feels like it's the first
time even if it's not really it's hard
to really get into it and there's a I
comfort I feel from actually just taking
the time before performance to remind
myself how it goes as I said I don't
really get nervous it's not there's no
kind of wacky routine that I have to do
in order to put myself in the right
frame of mind I'm happy to speak to
people backstage I'm happy to chat about
you know whatever else is going on you
know US Open and golf or whatever it is
that were that that we're thinking about
and then I just make sure that at the
very least I have a few minutes where I
can sort of go into the zone and and
really be able to concentrate I think
concentration is one of the most
important abilities are to be able to
concentrate well is one of the most
important things that a that a conductor
can have to really be able to focus on
whatever it is at that moment both in
terms of the performance but also taking
care of all the various things that go
along with the job because you know
being a music director is of course
mainly about conducting and delivering
good performances but there's so many
other questions that cross the desk in
terms of personnel and planning and
programming and and if I if I have to
think about everything at once nothing
really gets done that well so whatever
it is I try to do it and not worry about
the other things because I really
hopefully realize that whim if I've
taken care of one thing well then i can
let it go and move on to the next thing
so i try not to multitask actually
I'm pretty good at keeping my
concentration on stage and and today in
the performance there was a moment where
I almost lost focus and it was I don't
know if it was my fault or not but
anyway I turned to pages in a very in
the Gruber trumpet and show it's a very
very complicated piece and it was
actually the most complicated section
the most dangerous section to lose lose
your place if I messed up I probably
wouldn't have been able to get back on
so it was a really scary moment I wasn't
really thinking as I turn the page of
them and this particular piece is very
important to turn the pages really well
at the right time and of course only one
one leaf at a time I i usually am able
to stay really in the in the moment and
in the performance and if I'm tired
that's that's when I tend to lose my
concentration I I I sometimes think well
you know my kids are very important to
me I think about them a lot and I'll go
through an entire concert and I'll think
oh I didn't think about my kids once
during these last two hours
I think being well-prepared helps you
focus i think i like to go into a
rehearsal or a concert knowing that i
know how it's going to go not that i
know exactly how it will play out or how
will feel musically or artistically but
i don't i just don't allow myself to
enter a situation without doing adequate
preparation and that means focusing
beforehand but also creating the
situation in which it's possible to be a
hundred percent focused in the moment
and you know I I my wife laughs when I
say this because I work hard and I and I
keep a difficult schedule I say that I'm
fundamentally lazy and the only thing
that's stronger than my natural laziness
is this absolutely pathological need to
be one hundred percent prepared so in a
way it doesn't quite make sense but I
really you know I just it's one thing
that I just I never would allow myself
to do is to show up being less than
prepared and that's that's the one thing
you can control you can't control what
happens externally but you can control
your level of preparation and so that
gives you confidence and that makes it
possible to to I think really give give
the best in when when the when the
pressures on